i'm hannah montana again
the old hannah reveals losing its shock
value lil na's x
recently trolled hannah montana on
tick-tock and
now miley cyrus is getting in on the fun
i make jokes all the time i'm just as
make fun of myself as everyone else does
on sunday the rapper shared
an epic parody of the disney channel
classic on
tick tock reenacting what he calls quote
every episode of hannah montana playing
hannah slash miley stewart in his
own blonde wig dramatically revealing
his identity as the pop star
i can't keep doing this lily i can't
keep living this live stop
stop the music
i'm hannah montana oh my god
okay so the 21 year old rapper has a
point
this happened a lot during the series
because you know hannah was supposed to
be living a secret double life and all
i'm hannah montana
i'm hannah montana you're hannah montana
please don't interrupt me this is really
huh see what i mean i was in shock lil
nas wrote in the caption on his tick
tock video quote
i hope miley don't block me for this
well not only did she
not block him miley who starred in the
hit series from 2006 to 2011
did little nas one better duetting with
his video playing hannah's best friend
lily i can't keep doing this lily
i can't keep living this live stop stop
the music
i'm hannah montana again the old hannah
reveals losing his shock value
you do this every week miley she
captioned the clip quote
what lily is really thinking when miley
presses send on
another hannah reveal okay so this might
not have been the reunion that fans had
in mind
but last year miley did give us this
you are gonna be shook it this
is the reunion of the decade my bff that
shared the screen with me for the last
15 years uh i'm honored
to call her my on and off screen bad ass
friend that
whether it's for hannah or miley is
always
right there when i need her the 28 year
old singer chatted with her former
co-star emily osmond
aka lily during an episode of miley's
bright-minded live with miley series on
instagram this is when
we were like bff denim on dead
man yeah coral i said 2006
i do remember that day too yes very much
so this was one of our was it our first
or
second season that was season one that's
what i think so too and this was our
first day of like really hanging out